these kids can make the whole thing on
their phone put on Soundcloud and be a
mobster would break in a week and that
was actually truly the seed which led to
be investing in Facebook and Twitter for
me starting Wine Library TV this is true
story I don't tell it often what is the
most common complaint you get in your
opinion it sits around most common
complaint I get is you do not love
losing you lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what up vlog pretty busy day I'll be
role from what I'm hearing on this
Monday bunch of big clients are in
executive some boat jangles the board
I'm on if you're from the Carolinas or
Southeast you know that incredible chain
telecom companies in town some new
business stuff just a busy Monday
nothing too crazy weekly be sports cards
I've got the fever stupid I don't care
about reports I care about your
individual things there's happy is [ __ ]
thirty nine year olds I'm happiest [ __ ]
at forty four like that's a generic
study that took a base of certain
thousands of people and now people like
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna be unhappy a thirty
nine you're not gonna be unhappy at 39
you can be happy or unhappy at one and
at 100 it's [ __ ] mindset do you have
self esteem do you actually have self
esteem do you actually are you actually
in a mindset where you can deal with
other people's judgment [ __ ] this report
focus on yourself
pink is popping out this way focus on
away we've got some mozi trying to make
me like a hundred thousand decisions
yesterday while the message make
millions of decisions every nice one she
would be what's your advice for a
stay-at-home mom that wants X ray so I
think I think back to jab jab jab right
hook I think when somebody wants extra
income they go for the sale too quick so
they look at Pinterest they understand
you know as you know because you read it
for me it's not something I'm spending a
lot of time on which you know and but
there's plenty of other you know thought
leaders and users that are talking about
it
so somebody stumbles across that concept
the way I talk about tick tock or other
things and says yes I want to do that
and the problem is because they want
extra side how so money like to save up
for their Disneyland trip which is so
amazing the problem is they don't the
discipline to build an actual community
going for the clothes right so hey you
could get lucky and have a single pin
that goes viral that goes to your
Shopify page and sells your thing but
the way to build in any platform
including Pinterest is to put out a lot
of content that's just valuable and may
just come back to your blog or your shop
without going in for that hard sell in
essence romance
it's the odds of like rolling up on
somebody me like you want to go into my
hotel room at the bar low romance for a
couple months
works and so it's about putting out
content that brings value whether that
comes in video form whether that's
infographics it leads to self awareness
how do you actually make good content
are you good photographer can you draw
can you make a video cuz it all plays
out Pinterest and that works on
Pinterest and it works everywhere else
self awareness of how to create patience
romance to create a community which then
allows you to go in for the ask after
you've built up the equity the best way
to make a little side hustle and stay at
home on Pinterest is to think about
cashing in nine months in not nine
minutes
so no one taught me I was like damn
[ __ ] I'd do it myself don't put me on
damn [ __ ] it I do myself everyone scared
to go talk to [ __ ] I do myself
everyone scared to be number one [ __ ] it
I do myself
Oh better cash out every month
[Applause]
he's our baby
I can take him
I was with you the whole time
you the whole time
she's the rap
[Applause]
and her iphone is charged
[Music]
oh thanks a Monday did a ton of meetings
up most of it was beer old bought a ton
of [ __ ] sports cards then I went to
Barclays Center a little WWE big shadow
to Hunter Hearst appreciate the
hospitality and going at it tomorrow AJ
and I got into tech because I read a
article in a magazine that I picked up
on a trip to Napa called a magazine
called business 2.0 this is true story I
don't tell it often I literally pick up
a you know I'm at the airport I'm in the
wine business I'm eating magazines
doesn't scream tech
yeah this was 2000 when were you a
freshman in college this is a 506 yep
it was alive I'm in Napa we're in the
tech business cuz I'm in I'm in I'm
afraid I'm innovating in the wine
business because I have a website and I
do email and I'm buying Google AdWords
people have heard that before but I pick
up a magazine cuz my flight was delayed
and literally read it like read this
business 2.0 it was about domain names
like fish calm is 48 million dollars I'm
like what and it was less about that
hyperbole like sports cards it was more
about like there was something that just
clicked and my chemicals and when I
landed I called AJ I called AJ at a
Friday night or a Saturday from Friday
night he was that that is like first
college party or second it's definitely
first month is the first one and I'm
like bro I'm just like you need to leave
the parties I got I'm gonna go outside
with doing a cake whatever she's up to
plotting and so like I like literally
I'm like I'm gonna change your life this
is literally what the opening line was
I'm like I think I see something it's
like my third day in college he's like
alright brother
talk to you tomorrow like but like no
actually describe where they only got 15
minute call longer yeah I don't have a
frat house
is that true yeah you gotta be real and
that was actually truly the seed which
led to be investing in Facebook and
Twitter before me starting my library TV
AJ started Jets thas the first blogger
in the family he started Jets TV a
couple months before Wine Library TV in
his dorm room like it was the seed and I
almost even in telling you this story
feel like we're gonna be at the combine
or at the Senior Bowl or at the draft or
it's gonna be a Tuesday afternoon and
like I feel like we're over one
conversation away from innovating in the
sports business arena in a way that
transcends it I believe that to be true
where we just need one sec out we just
need one everybody we're competing with
needs to be perfect for 12 rounds we
literally need one conversation to win
in business right now we're trying to
impact young men's life for a legacy and
AJ striving for happiness and like and
I'm macro [ __ ] I'm creating macro air
cover for whatever the [ __ ] we want to
do forever
[Music]
you know what's up guys Jason we are at
hunt in fish club with Alex
my buddy crispy it's not paying
attention we're waiting for Gary he's
finishing up a meeting and then we're
gonna hopefully film the intro to weekly
v8 about it
we're waiting on Gary let's go I think
it's like I'm really heavy back where I
wasn't on dailyvee yes and I love people
it doesn't show any analytics just
logical I got people watching the TV
we're really treating it as a friend and
that's right
I'm really happy with it yeah are you
enjoying it I am are we experimenting
enough I'm trying to do more I want to
do yeah I want to do more like I'm
married
I'll watch I'll watch two or three of
the last ones this weekend but I think
we need to experiment a lot more like I
feel like that's a strength of mine that
I need to always push everyone who's
taking it thank you so much man
keep doing okay what uh yeah do you
wanna do you want to go there not walk
towards you yeah go
just like blocking out the noise in the
chaos of Times Square you need to block
out the noise of the judgement your
mother your father the cynicism block it
out you can't hear it do you understand
you can't [ __ ] hear it
[Music]
like you posted something
exact well like your Instagram is it
oh the art the art gallery looked away
did that I have all these people like
nah Gary can't post that because it's
gonna [ __ ] up like nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your [ __ ] art you like nobody
they look in the feed I'm not going to
your account be like oh it's
aesthetically pleasing you're fresh you
know why everybody's worried about them
I'm worried about putting out [ __ ] that
helps every post why I win is I sit
there I'm like why would this be good
for you not why does this make me look
good every single post that I see 99% of
it comes from one filter how is this
gonna make me look good with this cool
person with this hot good-looking person
I've got this new thing I'm on this
fancy thing I'm at Coachella rolling
loud courtside how does this make me
look good the [ __ ] values that bring in
any of us and I'm sure to see resentment
start to build just like the popular
kids in your high school freshman year
you want to be [ __ ] friends with them
by senior year you like [ __ ] those
people that's what's happening on
Instagram those pop the people in this
would have better be real careful
they're about 30 seconds away from your
thing turning on that that's great that
you're taking another [ __ ] selfie
with a celebrity I'm real happy for you
that you're dating another model it's
really cool that your boyfriend bought
you a new car great private jet dick
great Valenciano
Congrats [ __ ] the resentments
buildings
right what's what do you do like you
imagine making a video where you like
hey if your kid watch this let me tell
you what my uncle taught me in fourth
grade so when I three like where's that
bro
the number one person in the NBA that
goes up my list as the guy who takes a
photo makes a video tomorrow Instagram
showing him trying to make a [ __ ]
thing that we all do crumpled up paper
and missing it and be like and just like
real like that thing will go bananas
feel me my friends like I've rich
friends powerful friends outside of like
the cool Gary Vee there's Gary
Vaynerchuk who rolls with real [ __ ] and
when they see me like posting like words
cards or like going garage saling but
like the [ __ ] are you doing and I'm like
what I want dick you worry about
yourself
that's why yes sir I'm helping people
anyway people like when people want
money
I read my comments that I cool step1
be rich right like you know like like
they're like cool Gary be like you
telling you to invest $1,000 into sports
cards I don't have money like I kept
listening I'm like okay let me show you
what I do when I know money take five
dollars go garage silly I make it 80
take 80 the next weekend and make it 130
that and the sports car thing is gonna
make kids rich I'm not to make a bunch
of gets rich rich
[Music]
and mark I think I think once people
start making the world about happiness
not money then this is gonna make a lot
more logic because a lot of people go
for it have a nice home in Summit New
Jersey right now make for 12 a year
life is good kids in private school good
[ __ ] Geneva Jersey Shore house like good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] and they're gonna listen
to us to Jersey bozos and I'm like [ __ ]
it I'm unhappy I'm going for it and the
story for Hank is it's actually gonna
fail because what Hank was was a number
six he was a number six a great number
six you know it's the Scottie Pippen
thing Scottie Pippen is all-time
overrated in my opinion because he had a
great all-time number one hiding it and
when he went to Portland and he went to
Houston no and and by the way Hank right
now at for 12 years listening to us and
go for it let me just finish the song I
can see you want to jump in go you have
to go go bathroom so go I'll finish this
go go take a peek so let me finish my
thought
one i find it fascinating that mark
couldn't hold it like I just think
that's all-time interesting out of all
the things number two on the Scottie
Pippen thing it's not to raise Scottie
and of course it's coming from a Knicks
fan who's bitter but Hank if you're
listening Marx right not because of the
money but because of the happiness
because you're 44 and your life is good
but you hate your [ __ ] job you hate
it you you really know you actually hate
it but you like your life at what you
need to ask yourself is do you like your
life because of the financial things
that are happening and that you look
happy versus actually being happy
because I can tell you when you make
that jump and you fail and you have to
have the shame and that's the word I'm
going to use the shame to move your
family out of Summit and move into
another town and you got a twelve and a
nine year old who are now crying because
they're going to a different school and
they went from being fancy to maybe less
fancy like that is a lot of carnage that
most people don't have the stomach for
the problem is that nobody tells you is
that at 72 years old you spend the next
20 years of your life in regret because
you weren't happy and that is not
[ __ ] easy and I don't say this
lightly but when I hear mark say go for
it I actually understand it be
I spend a lot more time analyzing what
70 and 80 and 90 year old say and I
understand why a 44 year old doesn't
have the strength to disappoint their
kids or to look stupid and from their
friends or to like confuse the world and
it's easier at 27 even with a new kid
than it is a 44 which is why I love the
Internet
mark and I are by problem we would be
totally different men in our careers if
the internet didn't come along if you
listened to his stories Google and
diapers and and landing page and $500
check and the pit we are the byproducts
of our age of the entrepreneurs that had
practical opportunity on the internet
that would have never existed if we were
40 years earlier that's what I want for
everybody to realize we understood that
and that's what we navigated on you can
have a side hustle too so we talked
about Hank quitting let's talk about
Hank
instead of golfing for four hours on
Saturday let's talk about Hank instead
of coming home and having a glass of
wine and watching the news The Daily
Show or sports if you're really unhappy
with what you do for a living give me
back those 14 hours that you waste each
week and set up a landing page set up an
Instagram account around Star Trek or
soccer or sports cards side hustle
practicality with patience where you
build it we're where Mark and Lev had to
look at each other and say [ __ ] maybe
there's something here now notice what
he did he did what I do do [ __ ] that's
and then let the market show you there's
something there and then grow right like
the time this goes brother it's the
weeds it's pulling the weeds too many
people are entitled and don't want to
waste their time when their time ain't
worth [ __ ]
oh it puts me first hey what is the most
common complaint you get in your DMS it
sits around most common complaint I get
is around lack of patience really like
hey Gary Vee I've been doing this for
three months nothing's happened or you
told me to try things I've tried three
things skiing cooking and garage saleing
and it doesn't work you know it's like
it's um it's a it's a it's a game of
looking for excuse of why the practical
advice isn't right you know like common
complaint is I tried now what to see
like literally half-assed efforts as an
excuse to not actually do it it's like
doing one pushup
and being like yo doesn't [ __ ] work
what's one piece of advice you would
tell every teenager today
um I would tell every single teenager in
the world that other people's opinions
are the biggest poison to their
happiness and that them worrying about
what the popular kids think them
worrying about what you know some of the
random comments and their tick-tock or
you know Instagram are them worrying
about other people's opinions is the
easiest way to continue to be unhappy or
how to build a foundation of unhappiness
and how to get insular with themselves
and and focus on themselves and more
importantly don't judge others which
that's then lets you not have their
judgment hit you that whole thematic how
did you I mean naturally is there
anything that you like realize when you
were young that I think getting picked
on for not speaking English was a huge
help because I I somehow through lack of
DNA or circumstance got comfortable with
being on the outside everyone's so
desperate to be on the inside and I got
really happy on the outside
um and you see what I'm going oh yeah I
just I feel like I got comfortable being
an outsider immigrant you don't forget
this is something very forgotten little
fact of my life when I was a kid growing
up Russia was the evil empire like my
entire first like kind of eighth grades
like Russia was the actual enemy like
terrorism and I was Russian and like
people like like it was a thing I was
bad at school and so I just got very
used to being on the outside I ate like
weird food you know like like my friends
would come over like what's that we
don't soup your mom's make it sound like
it's borscht [ __ ] yeah you know like it
I got I got very comfortable on the
outside I don't need other people's
acceptance I need my own and then that
is deep [ __ ] happiness
[Music]
did your parents help you with that yes
nice well I think they've helped me by
loving me my mom loved me but she loved
me so much but she didn't coddle me
that's you know this why talk about
perfectly parity in circumstances I got
loved but I got punished there were
circumstances when I got out of line she
spanked me when I got bad grades
punished me but I was the best there's
just like get your [ __ ] together in
school there's accountability there was
no delusion I was on the outside I was
on the [ __ ] outside and I played in
games that were merit-based and it's
business you got it I liked sports in
business because no parents opinion
mattered either I made 83 dollars today
shoveling snow or I did it
either I went three for four in baseball
and hit a game-winning double where I
didn't I love Mary
nobody's opinion so I don't like the
Olympics but the judges
cool right but that's why I've always
had a weird relationship with boxing I
love it cuz it's the ultimate merit
mano-a-mano know where to [ __ ] hide
but if one guy doesn't knock the other
guy out it goes to the judges you know
yeah
frustrated frustrated but that's real
life - life is about judges people do
get fired because their boss is bad at
the judgement right like so there's
acceptance I'm not crippled by humans
you know mistakes and issues and
shortcomings and hypocrisy I'm not
crippled by it I recognize it I'm not in
love with it but I'm not in this kind of
like we're [ __ ] you know too much
optimism overlaid unlike if your [ __ ]
don't be a boxer look to me no matter
what anybody says there's a counter of
like do something about but America is
move Costa Rica's nice
people want the excuse people are
addicted to excuses hmm I lived in a
family that demonized complaining
demonized it too much I think it led to
not being able to be vulnerable you know
so like everything in balance but like
demonized complaining okay I don't want
it to make up I do it cuz I'm good at it
but it's not something that I see myself
pursuing it - um what I want to do is I
want to be an actress I know it's gonna
happen for sure okay I just don't know
how to get my foot in the door and the
people where do you live violet would
you move to California if if that's what
it takes not doing that's what it takes
then there's more things that it will
take but but speak - well it's really
funny like you don't think people want
to be a beauty influence over two
hundred fifty two thousand five centers
well
do you okay what did you do you just did
people think they have to go take a
course people feel like they have to go
and have a connection you just did what
you can also do is do that again you can
move to California you could go to
auditions you can work in co-working
spaces and be around people and stumble
into people you can thoughtfully look at
every single person who likes one of
your photos and look at their profile
and see if they work at CIA or WME you
can do what you've already done at your
young age you did which is why you have
what you have but because you put being
an actress on a mental pedestal you
don't see it the same way you do makeup
artistry yeah
just understand I mean how brilliant is
that are you like my god mom you like
this guys like I'm so thankful I believe
I will I will literally standby away for
that yes tomorrow so move tomorrow let's
go
so wait you shouldn't leave here right
now and move hold on okay okay I'm dying
to leave oh good you're moving to LA
anyway easily you besides buying sports
cards and trading them I think you good
news there's a lot of receptionist jobs
in LA no [ __ ] but you have to move you
don't want to be a makeup influencer you
are you don't want to be a receptionist
you want to be an actress you go and
move to LA and be a receptionist keep
hustling your makeup artistry because
you might be able to get some more funds
to make it sustainable so that you're
not at risk to go take those auditions
and those networking because the
receptionist job may get you fired when
you go to lunch at one o'clock but what
you're really doing is an audition and
if you keep growing your beauty business
and start DMing beauty brands you might
make enough brand deals to allow you to
do that full time instead of
receptionist until you get the actress
job so go harder how many beauty brands
do you DM every night
got it what could Hershey's do I think
that they should get into meaningful
chocolate extensions I mean when you
hear species you hear chocolate right
and so whether it's direct-to-consumer
chocolate shakes protein shakes like
line extensions where chocolate has
permission I also would probably create
a super premium chocolate bar it's like
a twenty five dollar Hershey's bar that
elevates the brand which then makes kind
of their core products seem like a good
deal so that's what I would do with
Hershey's li bai's I think really needs
to think about a couple things so like
what's funny about there's talk about an
iconic brand that with denim what I
think Levi's should consider is like
really
Levi's feels like the brand can really
win the first you know kind of smart
pants game you know when your pants kind
of tell you you need to lose weight cuz
your waist is connected to your phone I
think they're smart if ocation of jeans
is gonna be a real business and I think
it's Levi's for the taking I think
supreme needs to be careful I think
Supremes extending its brands so it's
funny Hershey's I want them to extend it
supreme I want them to be thoughtful
about where they extend it right they're
doing a ton of JB's with other brands
and eventually it becomes a saturation
play so there are big business so I have
a lot of empathy for that but I would
tighten that brand up and be thoughtful
about where it's extending because when
you think about brands like Playboy it
extended its brand to everything and
eventually gonna mean anything and so I
think Supremes to be very thoughtful
especially cuz it's cool to not
overextend their brands at places that
are not cool that eventually makes them
not cool well it's less about whether
they should stick to it's just that no
matter how much the brand that's dorky
pays them they should not do JB's with
them that's a good one medium so I
should have disclosed that I was an
early investor and medium
illegal likes that monster next to mark
you know it's funny they they've gone
you know pay for content which I'm a
buyer of I've been clicking I have found
myself in the last 12 months
clicking articles that I find on social
and then want to read them and they're
behind paywalls and I haven't paid yet
but last week there was an article I
really wanted to read and I was close
and I thought that was an interesting
chemical feeling that I was close to
signing up for something that I'd
probably would never use again which
meant that I was happy paying $108 to
read that article because it was $9 a
month and I knew that I would never use
it and forget about it forever and pay
108 year just to read this one sports
article and so I think medium has that
potential for sure and I think original
creative content think of medium like
serious if they can get some original
writers that only live in that
environment their subscription product
and get really good and that's what I
think Twitter story testing I love that
I think every platform should be in the
stories business ephemeral content works
that's why it works on Instagram that's
why it's working on YouTube that's why
it's working on Spotify and if Twitter
if you're telling me right now the
Twitter's testing a story's product that
excites the [ __ ] out of me everybody
should be using stories across all these
platforms and the LinkedIn it's just
contextual to the audience like business
centric or you know you know my take on
LinkedIn it's starting to become more
Facebook stories is a function that
humans have told us we like we like that
style of distribution
give me something stackable that
disappears I like that oh by the way
television and newspapers and radio were
in stories format only the internet sits
there forever like like everything else
that we were consuming in traditional
media was built on a ephemeral content
the news played and then went away
didn't stick there forever so you know
you would watch a TV show and then later
VHS came in later DVR came so this is a
human behavior we're super okay with
consuming content that goes away
just let me consume it in a non
frictionless environment and and in a
friction and friction less environments
use me and that's why I think stories as
a function is going to become a very
meaningful genre and it already is and
it doesn't surprise me that every
platform is building out their quote
unquote stories capability
all right going into a Mi'kmaq meeting
pop that up right there
Mick back up on the board and kind of
company you're not kill me the board
meeting so that was see you later Dustin
yeah and not only that you know why I
get so I'm so hyped then putting out
what I'm putting out if I haven't
screamed the end when I was 14
there was no internet if you want to be
a producer
you can actually lay your [ __ ] bed or
sit on the bus first of all thank you
you've got the technology in your pocket
not like you have to save up money to
get into the studio and buy some janky
ass [ __ ] right right that's number one
yes that's that just gave me goosebumps
that's how a true it is I I went to a
school that was 80% african-american and
like low-income it was a hood school and
everybody want to be in a rapper and
like I watched my friends have to sell
[ __ ] nickel bags or hustle or [ __ ]
steal just to get into the studio one
time for an hour don't worry about it
now don't even don't even don't don't
even look at anymore now now these kids
can make the whole thing on their phone
put it on soundcloud and be a mobster
would break in a week so like I just
want them to have that perspective like
no like you it's never ever been easier
to live your dream you want to work in
Hollywood you can lay down on your bed
at night you can be on the bus or the
subway doing it you can DM every single
person and one out of eight hundred and
thirteen of them replies that says I
love your spirit come and be an intern
there is it's real the Internet is real
and I don't want it and not listen do I
believe the system's rigged yes do I
believe there's suppression yes do I
believe in circumstance do my big thing
I told this kid long ago and I use it a
lot like look he this kid situation was
rugged like mom dad dad [ __ ] up bad
like bad and and I remember was like a
tough one
it was like in real life not on the
internet before even all that scary me
[ __ ] I was like listen hey listen please
listen I'm like if one person in the
world ever came out of your situation
then you can too and he brought a lot
six people that came from his spot and
his situation
I just need people remember that what
happened is we whatever reason we had
the right mentality through either
parenting or circumstance or just
natural DNA that let us look at
adversity as a springboard to success
and a lot of other people are insecure
and take adversity as what builds them
and that's why I'm putting out so much
content to try to build up their
self-esteem it's right the reason you
did that was you weren't scared of know
the people that are fancy they're like
Gary D but my time is worth something
like you know values their time the most
the people that are doing the least I'm
all these people like saying give you
some [ __ ] I value my time I should
get paid what I deserve I'm like hiding
so much free [ __ ] always forever and by
the way Sam my time is worth more than
yours people acting like their times
how's your time worth something when
nobody's paying usually I ain't doing
that video for free they should pay me
I'm like well why aren't they the market
told you they don't want you like I'm
like there's 74 million other video
makers sorry of course and now and now
some 20 year old thinks you got a pic
for what nobody who's ever heard of you
is your beat fresh and even if it's not
beats is an arbitrage of Fame people pay
for somebody because they're gonna say
oh it's true say hey oh wise you're
asking for a favor every producer - you
know the producer name you know the DJ
MC thing switched like a lot of these
kids aren't historians a hip-hop the MC
was the supporter of the DJ it flipped
so I don't know what audacious table
you're standing on but if you get
[ __ ] the baby to use your beat he's
doing you a [ __ ] favor I pay the baby
if I was a producer I pay Magnus Thalia
I paid a baby and hope they think it was
[ __ ] hot
I mean do um a number like here's me and
what's your paper
[Music]
you talk about bouncing being your
biggest fan and being humble by
recognizing you can have opposite
feelings like everyone's so scared of
like I'm a contradiction no you feel
different things like you know the
reality is is like staying humble comes
natural to me I don't want a big time
anybody like no matter how much I
accomplish it's not interesting to me to
impose my success on somebody in our
human interactions right that doesn't
mean that that's a contradiction
ironically me saying you can have a
contradiction I think they think you
think it's a contradiction of having
wild conviction and confidence and being
humble I don't I've seen them in a in a
layer the way I understand why people
think even I set it up as a
contradiction it's just not like they're
too easy feelings to bounce I live it I
know it's true I have the most [ __ ]
confidence that I can win and I also
have no interest of imposing my
abilities on you the contradiction to
you know confidence is self-doubt not
humility humility is just kind you're
welcome
right I don't I don't right
yeah it's just nice like I guess I know
that I've been successful in my
profession and people admire you what am
I supposed to make you feel less than me
it's so stupid you do you will grow a
better beard than me like you know like
like like I I think that's where the
humility comes in it's like cool yes I'm
good at this and there are many things
you're better at than me and like yes I
understand that we're in the moment
where what I do is cool like sports
cards is cool I also remember what it
was the dorkiest orc [ __ ] of dork thank
you okay
Wow so what are those things
yeah and and and it's not just sports
cards it's also sneaker flipping it's
why I think all these thicker flippers
are about to come and dominate sports
cards like actually I'm take a photo of
this like I think like I think it's the
same game this is me making content like
this is the same game this in this same
game listen this like this and this it's
the same game so like I just think it's
the same game like it's called supply
and demand it's called having courage to
say no when a grownup offers you less
money than you want for a card when I
was 14 and some old man comes to my
table and says how much you offer that
bojack's I'm like 8 and I gonna give you
five I'm like no 8 5 8 learning that
versus the friends that I did shows with
when the guy said I'll give you 5 and
they're like when he found thinking
before like that's learning that that
figuring out that this Don row set that
was in Canada some kid walks around a
show in 1992 and has Burger King Don
Roose pace ball packs and he's like
would you buy this would you buy this in
everyone's laughing at him I could hear
it cuz I'm watching right that's what I
do and I'm like who's that kid and
what's he selling and what is that they
get to me he's like hey you want these
Burger King Don Roose cards like from
Canada and I'm like I'll take them off
took a huge risk bottom all priced them
super expensive everyone's like what the
[ __ ] I'm like these are rare because
they were this is pre-internet there's
no [ __ ] Canadian Burger King [ __ ]
cards made for Don Roose next thing you
know other dealers are buying off me
they were like the hit of the whole show
I learned that when there's a scarcity
of something if you can build awareness
of it
and if you believe that to be true not
like you're a scam artist so I learned a
ton how to negotiate with grownups how
to see market dynamics had a price how
to set up my table why do I put the
Lucca if it's Lucas the hottest right
now I realized that if I put Luca in the
top-left corner because the Luca and
Lamar are the hottest cards I have that
that would work because that's how
people read pages they start at the top
left and so it made people stop at my
table so I was watching over time I
watched humans and realized I was
stopping more people at my table than
other tables because I was putting the
hottest cards in top left corner because
that's how people read pages I learned
why do you think my content does well
because I knew where to put the Lucas
that's it
got it yeah so I think this is really
cool Danya I think you should end the
entire the entire episode with what just
happened here in last 20 minutes there's
so much it just happened good week
they all are cards [ __ ] this report
focus on yourself
yep yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
love yep yep yep
yep yep hey guys it's Gary this is
Mark's first tick-tock what is the most
iconic thing you're gonna say now that
we look back in 13 years and look back
and say wow jetzt eight yes my that was
perfect
total pantry
[Music]
2015 that's fun by the way my eyes are
going hi this is a crazy sad news wine
club
I think I'm literally like 18 months
away from like glasses which is nuts cuz
I'd laser laser vision sucks
I'm pissed sorry you didn't do fairly V
this week you shouldn't you shouldn't
you should you should have just told
them the [ __ ] year you're not my
exports cards you're making a huge
mistake now if you're not I've been
watching a bunch of you a bunch of you
have been dopes you're not educated and
you're buying the wrong grading
companies you're probably the wrong
grades you're brought me the wrong
actual rookie card get educated for 25
to 50 hours then start purchasing now
who's caring you said by sportswriters
by random [ __ ] somebody gonna karate
yells buying them fifty dollars for the
cards worth four sets or [ __ ] sense
in yoga you guys stink you stink there's
spider there you don't have a title and
I'm [ __ ] I stink because I don't know
because I had no title we missed that my
text is not doing well yeah I think I'm
better than all of you no I unless I get
scheduled time to sit down and do it
I haven't been able to perform and now
that all my trips are canceled I'm not
doing anything
[Music]
concept is I'm going to talk about how
unbelievable I am at being okay with
dropping balls am I said you didn't know
God like I'm just gonna throw them all
up and try to catch damages from this
you gonna say go and I'm gonna go do
rock make sure that when we use like me
not me and the content that we don't use
your hand because your weird thumb is
[ __ ] my grams like I wish I his face
what do you know I like your face okay I
think we have to be chummy like a
spaceman I did two people Loki really
think he rocks off like he's winning
completely leveraging my cloud d-roc I
went there because I'm plotting fun I
used to go there
I [ __ ] fly I'm a plotter shunya Plata
PLO tt egg yeah what does carry up to
I'm not an entrepreneur mulatto you know
there might be you know this is
literally why we document because like
my brain just went to like 13 years from
now like that being a term hey guys I
don't think I'm going entrepreneur
anymore
[Music]